Here's a pretty good answer.
We definitely want to match single words and then you can possibly have 1 hypen
and then you can have more letters if you like.
This regular expression definitely matches well-liked.
It also matches html--maybe the h, t, and m will match the first part,
and the l will match the second part.
It definitely rejects a-b-c and a--b.
However, 1 problem with this regular expression is that it does not accept
single letter words like "a" or "i".
To see why, just look at these 2 plus signs.
This requires 1 or more letters here and 1 or more letters there,
That's at least 2 letters.
We might be tempted to fix it up by making 1 of these a star,
but now we mistakenly accept things like just "-a".
No letters here, the hypen, and then some more letters--
well, that didn't work.
What if I try to make the other one a star?
Well, dual problem--now we'll mistakenly accept things like "a-".
Well, this is a bit of a challenge.
What we really want is for this hypen and the second word to be grouped together,
and either they're both there or they're not.
It's as if I really want this question mark to apply to both the hyphen
and also the [a - z]+.
We don't know how to do that yet, but you'll get a chance after we've learned how
to fix this up in the homework.